[Music]
my kid is the kind that dumps bins to
find what he wants at playtime any
simple tips on the best practical way to
store and organize toys how do you
organize your toys josh
good guys and bad guys uh yes
that's a line from a lot of people use
things as well so i had ocd as a kid and
there was a whole lot of chaos in our
homes and quite often we try to organize
our lives because we're trying to
organize this internal
chaos yeah and how well does that work
if i have a thousand items and i'm just
putting them in a bunch of clutter
coffins a bunch of bins and storing them
in my little tiny mausoleums now i've
got just a bunch of dead useless
wasteful things that are getting in the
way
it's organizing the chaos but organized
chaos is still
chaos yeah and so when i was a kid and
we had a lot of chaos because my mother
was an alcoholic there was drug and
alcohol abuse in the home there was some
physical abuse and i was really young
my father specifically abusing my mother
my first memory as a child is of my
father abusing my mother and so the only
way that i had control was what i ate
and also how i tidied up my toys and so
i had some gi joe figurines and i had
three little bins
and
i would put the weapons in one bin
the good guys in one bin and the bad
guys in another bin here's a metaphor
for you occasionally some of the good
guys and bad guys
would switch sides
that's good and
that was the first time i really
understood that hey maybe there's more
nuance to good and bad and not everyone
bad is good and not everyone good is bad
because these are constructs now i
wouldn't have had that vocabulary when i
was a very young kid but ryan tell me
about the stats for children
oh and because kids have a lot of toys
yeah so
um american children make up less than
three percent of the world's children
they consume about 40 of the world's
toys though so the average child in
america has uh nearly 300 toys but
here's the kicker they play with only
about 12 of them each day
so to answer this question head on i
would say the fewer
toys your child has
the less you have to worry about
organizing them and since they play with
only about 12 a day anyway they don't
need 300 toys right and so this is
ultimately a conversation about
boundaries right
first thing i would do if i'm brazilda
is i would go download the free
minimalist rule book 16 rules for living
with less the minimalists.com
rulebook
jordan if for the video version you can
put that up on the screen i'm sure but
we have that those rules
to help you
set up some boundaries for you and your
family they're not actual rules now
why is this important because we're not
saying ba hum bug
zero toys
is the best number of toys
no what we're saying is if your child
has 300 toys or 3 000 toys
it's actually going to get in the way of
quality playtime
and having a dozen toys or a few dozen
toys
that are in a bin
are so much better than having a dozen
bins
because what you're doing there is
you're organizing the chaos but having
just one bin with useful toys that fit
within any of those rules you want to
pick up maybe it's the seasonality rule
have i used this toy in the last 90 days
will i use it in the next 90 days maybe
it's the spontaneous combustion rule
maybe it's the just in case rule maybe
it's the emergency item rule although i
can't think of any toys it might be an
emergency item
who knows but if you have a bin this is
what we do with ella she likes to dump
out her bin as well
but whenever we set the stage at the end
of the night we talked about that
earlier in this maximal episode
at the end of each night we set the
stage or we shake the house
everything goes back into that bin
and if it doesn't fit in the bin then we
have to let go of the excess toys
dude it makes me think about
i had a friend uh it was well there were
it was two brothers
their
parents would
try to get them to set the stage
every night whether it was with their
clothes or with their toys
and it got to a point where i'm not
saying to do this but it was just
extreme their parents were like okay
anything that's left out i'm throwing
away i'm donating
so like
you know they yeah they would literally
gather up whatever was left over go
donate to the donation store i'm not
saying to do that with your kid but um
that's like yeah super extreme
uh yeah ella um she doesn't have that
many toys to dump out though i mean so
like that's um just going back to the
less toys you have the less you have to
clean up
um but yeah i mean i've seen ella's toys
and yeah she uh it's a pretty easy
cleanup for her and she also realizes
that when she stops playing with toys
other kids might enjoy them and that
actually brings her joy
to
donate those toys that once upon a time
she liked
but then she stopped getting value from
it maybe it's just that her other
friends don't like them now or it's run
its course she's no longer interested in
it it doesn't mean someone else won't be
interested in the future and by the way
i've never heard of ella complaining
about not having enough toys like she's
a very happy child yeah yeah yeah kids
rarely complain about the number of toys
that they have well i think about when i
was a kid complaining about the toys i
didn't have there was it was something
deeper going on inside of me mm-hmm um
there was a lack a lack yes yes
absolutely and we can get into my
childhood stuff but we've already done
that in our book love people use things
did you enjoy this standalone patreon
highlight if so you can listen to full
episodes of the minimalist private
podcast
available exclusively on patreon visit
patreon.com slash the minimalists or
click the link in the description your
support keeps our podcast and youtube
channel one hundred percent
advertisement free